well first I want to say thank you to
all of you for being here today and I
want to send a message of gratitude and
thanks to the solidarity that we have
received from every corner of our
country from our colleagues to our
neighbors we are grateful for your
solidarity your encouragement in your
support in the face of the most recent
xenophobic bigoted remarks from the
occupant of our White House I will
always refer to him as the occupant as
he is only occupying space it is not
embody the grace the empathy the
compassion the integrity that that
office requires and that the American
people deserve that being said I
encourage the American people in all of
us in this room and beyond to not take
the bait this is a disruptive
distraction from the issues of care
concern and consequence to the American
people then we were sent here with a
decisive mandate from our constituents
to work on everything from reducing the
cost of prescription drugs to addressing
our affordable housing crisis to
ensuring that the American people have
more than health insurance but health
care more recently thanks to the
partnership of chairman Elijah Cummings
and the advocacy of myself and a
coalition of advocates have worked with
for decades we held the first hearing on
childhood trauma and it's sitting in
that hearing as we heard about the many
manifestations interation
a childhood trauma in the wake of the
public health crisis an epidemic that
has gun violence in the wake of PTSD in
the awake of those battling substance
abuse disorder and a host of other
things it was impossible not to think of
the trauma that is being inflicted upon
children every day at our border at the
end of the day if we improve the
conditions of children in a cage they
are still in a cage and we are
viscerally vigorously and fundamentally
opposed to the criminalizing the
vilifying the mass detention and
deportation of migrant families who are
simply doing what is their legal human
right and that is to seek asylum in the
tradition of who we say we are as a
country a beacon of light and hope and
of refuge this is simply a disruption
and a distraction from the callous
chaotic and corrupt culture of this
administration all the way down we want
to get back to the business of the
American people and while we were sent
here reducing the cost of prescription
drugs addressing the public health
crisis an epidemic that is gun violence
addressing the racial wealth gap and yes
making sure that families stay together
I also would like to just underscore the
fact that despite the occupant of the
White House attempts to marginalize us
and to silence us please know that we
are more than a for people we ran on a
mandate to advocate for and to represent
those ignored left out and left behind
our Squad is big our squad includes any
person committed to building a more
equitable in just the world and that is
the work that we want to get back to and
given the size of this squad and this
great nation we cannot we will not be
silenced and now I'll invite
representative Omar to offer a few words
as well Thank You congresswoman Anna
Presley this country was founded on the
radical idea that we are created equal
and endowed by our Creator with in
inalienable rights and yes we have a
long way before we fully live up to
those values it is for this reason
precisely that we have to take action
when a president is openly violating the
oath he took to the Constitution of the
United States and the core values we
aspire to as Martin Luther King said all
we say to America is be true to what you
say
on paper I believe this is a pivotal
moment in our country the eyes of
history is watching us right now the
president is carrying out mass
deportation raids across this country in
each one of our districts right now the
president is committing human rights
abuses at the border keeping children in
cages and having human beings drinking
out of toilets this president who has
been credibly accused of committing
multiple crimes including colluding with
foreign government to interfere with our
election this is a president who has
overseen the most corrupt administration
in our history and pursued an agenda to
allow millions of Americans to die from
a lack of health care while he transfers
millions of dollars in tax cuts to
corporations this is a president who has
said grab women by the [ __ ] this is a
president who's called Platt black
athletes sons of [ __ ] this is a
president who has called black people
who come from black and brown countries
shitholes this is a president who has
equated neo-nazis with those who protest
against them in Charles Ville this is a
president who has openly violated the
very value our country aspires to uphold
equality under the law
religious liberty equal protection and
protection from persecution and to
distract from that he's launching a
plainly racist attack on four duly
elected members of the United States of
House of Representatives all of whom are
women of color this is the agenda of
white nationalists whether it is
happening in chat rooms or it's
happening on national TV and now it's
reached the White House Garden he would
love nothing more than to divide our
country based on race religion gender
orientation or immigration status
because this is the only way he knows he
can prevent the Solidarity of us working
together across all of our differences
the only way to prevent us confronting
the problems our country is facing
whether it is health care climate change
student debt or our endless wars this is
his plan to pit us against one another
this is how he can continue to enrich
his friends and distract us from the
detrimental policies that his
administration is pushing for so we can
either continue to enable this president
and report on the bile of garbage that
comes out of his mouth or we can hold
him accountable to his crimes we can
continue to turn a blind eye of the
multiple crimes he's accused of we can
stand while he violates peace peep
basic human rights and the
responsibilities the responsibilities
that his administration has for the
deaths of children on our border or we
can take action I have not made
impeachment central to my election or my
tenure but since the day that I'd gotten
elected I'd said to people it is not if
he will be impeached but when so it is
time for us to stop allowing this
president to make a mockery out of our
Constitution it's time for us to impeach
this president so now we're going to
have Alexandria or Castillo
congresswoman Alexandria Castillo
quartet I'll try to keep things as brief
as I can when I was a little girl my
father took me to the reflecting pool
here we were on a road trip
from New York to Florida to visit family
and I've told this story before but it
was my first time ever was visiting
Washington DC and it was my only time
visiting Washington DC for years it's
not decades and he rested me on the side
of the reflecting pool and had my toes
dip in the water and he had me look at
the Washington Monument had me look at
the Capitol had me look at the entirety
of the Capitol of our great country and
he looked at everything and he pointed
to all of it and he said this belongs to
all of us this belongs to you and it
belongs to me and so the first note that
I want to tell children across this
country is that no matter what the
president said
this country belongs to you and it
belongs to everyone and today that
notion that very notion was challenged
this weekend that very notion was
challenged so I am NOT surprised when
when the president says that for sitting
members of Congress should quote go back
to their own country when he has
authorized raids without warrants on
thousands of families across this
country I am NOT surprised that he used
that uses the rhetoric that he does when
he violates international human rights
and takes thousands of children away
from their families I am not surprised
that he has turned our public education
system under the leadership of Betsy
DeVos into a cash cow to enrich himself
and his friends I am not surprised when
he corrupts via the Secretary of
Transportation I am not surprised at
what he's doing but I also know that
we're focused on making it better
because we don't leave the things that
we love and when we love this country
what that means is that we propose the
solutions to fix it we love all people
in this country and that's why we
believe health care is a human right we
but we love all children in this country
and because we do that's why we fight
for education for all children through
college and so we'll stay focused on our
agenda and we won't get caught with them
because all of this is a distraction
it's a distraction from what's most
important and from our core values as
American citizens thank you thank you to
my sisters in service thank you all so
much for being here
as we all know the recent tweets and
words from the president are simply a
continuation of his racist and
xenophobic playbook we cannot allow
these hateful actions by the president
to distract us from the critical work to
hold this administration accountable to
the inhumane conditions at the border
that is separating children from their
loved
and caging them up in illegal horrific
conditions
I represent the third poorest
congressional district in this country
one that is made up working people who
have been targeted by this
administration and their actions and
words are hurting them today I was
elected to fight for them fight for the
13 congressional district they sent me
here to Congress to fight back against
the corporate assault in the corruption
in our country this means supporting an
impeachment inquiry of this president
and his actions by the administration
and his appointees sadly this is not the
first nor will it be the last time we
hear disgusting bigoted language from
the president we know this is who he is
and we know that he and his
administration are constantly engaged in
actions that harm residents and American
people in our country many members of
Congress have called for his impeachment
because of his utter disregard and
disrespect of the United States
Constitution and despite this and other
many attempts to distract us I remain
focused we remain focused on holding him
accountable to the laws of this land and
accountable to the American people
I heard urge House leadership many of my
colleagues to take action to impeach
this lawless president today and now
will take two or three questions Mary
I would just say that the experience
that he offered is in contradiction to
the experience that I have every day
including in the airport on my way here
there were many people who approached me
and who said I disagree with some of
your policies I'm an independent I'm a
Republican but I think what he did was
wrong and he won't apologize but I am
going to apologize so I have experienced
nothing in the wake of those comments
again but words of denouncing these
xenophobic bigoted words but again this
is a distraction and we should not take
the bait we can sit here and continue to
recycle his hateful rhetoric of which I
cannot feign surprise or inflated
outrage because he is if nothing else
predictable
what we are focused on are the hateful
policies that are draconian and
oppressive and life threatening and
Families separating that is being rolled
out by this administration every day
you might have noticed how when he said
go back to where you came from there was
an uproar through the through all of our
communities because every single person
who's brown and black at some point in
their life in this country heard that
now when he made the comment I know that
every single Muslim who has lived in
this country and across the world has
heard that comment and so I will not
dignify it with an answer
because I know that every single
islamaphobe every single person who is
hateful who is driven by an ideology of
uttering as this president is rejoices
in us responding to that and as
defending ourselves I do not expect
every time there is a white supremist
who attacks or there is a white man who
kills in in a school or in a movie
theater or in in a mosque or in a
synagogue I don't expect my white
community members to respond on whether
they love that person or not and so I
think it is beyond time it's beyond time
to ask Muslims to condemn terrorists we
are no longer going to allow the digna
fication of such ridiculous ridiculous
statement
no I will pick this and I think Alex has
a great answer for this I'll let her
finish it every single statement that we
make is from a place of extreme love for
every single person in this country it
is part of the Mandate of why we ran for
office and why we got elected every
single person wants to make sure that
they have people in the halls of
Congress that is fighting to make sure
that they have health care that they
have an education that is suitable in
the United States that they have access
to proper roads and bridges that they
have access to clean water and clean air
every single person here in the United
States knows that we are fighting every
single day to create a more perfect
union and to fight on their behalf now
when people say if you say a negative
thing about the policies in this country
you hate this country to me it sort of
speaks to the hypocrisy and Alex and I
were talking about this when this
president ran and until today he talked
about everything that was wrong in this
country and how he was going to make it
great and so for him to condemn us and
to say we are an American for wanting to
work hard to make this country be the
country we all deserve to live in
complete hypocrisy
I don't think it would have changed
anything because first of all he made
statements that were blatantly untrue so
whether he was citing comments or not
citing comments if he didn't have what
he wanted to say he would make it up
this president operates in complete bad
faith he does not operate in in good
faith and so that's one thing but second
second to the previous question as well
weak minds and leaders challenged
loyalty to our country in order to avoid
challenging and debating the policy this
president does not know how to make the
argument that Americans do not deserve
health care he does not know how to
defend his policies so what he does is
attack us personally and that is what
this is all about he can't look a child
in the face and he can't look all
Americans in the face and justify why
this country is throwing them in cages
so instead he tells us that I should go
back to the great borough of the Bronx
and make it better and that's what I'm
here to do thank you all so much for
being here we really do appreciate it
thank you very much